[موسيقى]
نبدا بتطورات الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
فقبل ساعات من انهاء الهدنه التي اعلنتها
روسيا اعلنت كيف ان مدينه سوليدار في دنيا
تحت سيطرتك وان القتال مستمر على محور باخ
موت في المقابل اكدت موسكو ان قواتها
تقدمت في المدينه واسقطت مسيره في القرن
وجددت التزامها بوقف اطلاق النار
الجديد داخل اوكرانيا يتابعه من ديني
بروما مع مراسل الجزيره عمر الحاج ومن
موسكو مع مراسل الجزيره امين درغامي لعرض
الموقف من الجانب الروسي والبدايه معك عمر
وهذا التاكيد من قبل الجن بانه ماذا لا
يسيطر على وضعه في سوريا
[موسيقى]
نعم عبد القادر هذا التاكيد هذا النفي
الاوكراني جاء قبل قليل على لسان المتحدث
باسم قياده المنطقه الشرقيه خلال قياده
العمليات في الجيش الاوكراني
الذي قال لا صحه للاخبار التي تتحدث عن
سيطره القوات الروسيه على مدينه سوريدار
وان القتال في تلك الجبهه في ذلك المحور
ما يزال مستمرا وانه حذر من يروج لمن
سماها بالدعايه الروسيه من العقاب من
المواطنين من بعض من قال انهم مواطنون
اوكرانيون يروجون لهذه الدعايه كذلك الام
قال
الشريفات التي تحدث باقتضاض عن سيد
العمليات العسكريه هناك همم قال ان القوات
الروسيه ومقاتل فاجنر قصفوا المدينه منذ
ساعات الليل
باكثر من 79
مره قصفت المدينه وقال انهم شنوا 10 هجمات
من محاور مختلفه ولكنه يؤكد مره اخرى ان
القوات الاوكرانيا موجوده في المدينه وان
هذه المدينه تحت سيطرتها ايضا كان هناك
تصريح لافت لرئيس لجنه الامن والدفاع في
البرلمان همم الاوكرانيا الرادا في ان
الذي اكد في وقت سابق حديثا شريفاتي وقال
ان القوات الاوكرانيه هي التي تسيطر على
مدينه سوريا هذه المدينه ذات الاهميه
الاستراتيجيه لكلى الجانبين والتي لابد
انها ستشهدوا معارك محتدمه لان السيطره
عليها تعني بطبيعه الحال اضعاف من يدافع
عن او تقويه من يحاول او تقويه جانبا من
يحاول التقدم باتجاه المدينه بعد ان اكدت
قوات الاوكرانيه ايضا اليوم ان المدينه
مدينه تحت السيطراتها بشكل كامل وانها لم
تخسر مناطقها التي حاجتها من القوات
الروسيه خلال الاسابيع الماضيه وبثت صورا
من داخل المدينه تظهر قتلى سقط نتيجه
القذف الروسي ضمن ما سمي بهن احاديه
الجانب التي قوات الاوكرانيا وتحدث
المسؤول الاوكرانيا عن عدم صحتها وان
القوات الروسيه لم تتوقف ساعه عن استهداف
المناطق الاوكرانيه سواء على جبهه وحتى
المناطق البعيده نسبيا عن جبهات القتال
هنا في ديني برو كان هناك ايضا صور بثتها
بثتها مجلس مدينه المقاطعه عن اسقاطي
مسيره همم روسيه موسى مسيره اطلقها الجيش
الروسي السقوطها على احد المنازل السكنيه
دون ان تعلق على وجود ضحايا قتلى ولكن
هناك جرحه وايضا هناك ضرر همم في منازل
المدنيين كذلك الامر كان هناك تصريح لافت
اليوم
الذي تحدث فيه عن تقدم من القوات
الاوكرانيه بشكل بطيء في محوري
كلها تعرضت لهجوم وتحدث عن خطف لبعض
الاطفال هناك ايضا تصريح في هذا الصدر عن
اجبار المواطنين عن الحصول على الجنسيه
الرو فكان قد ادلى به حاكم مقاطعه
زباريجيا لموظفين يعملون في محطه الطاقه
النوويه نستمع اليه ونستمع لما قال في هذا
الصدر
القوات الروسيه الضغطه النفسيه والجسديه
على السكان المدنيين في الاراضي المحتله
في مدينه انرزودار في منطقه زاباروجيا
اجبرت قوات الاحتلال الروسيه حوالي ثلاثه
الاف عمل من محطه زباروجيا للطاقه النوويه
على الحصول على جوازات السفر الروسيه تم
اخراج العمله الاوكرانيه من التداول في
المدينه من خلال تهديد رجال الاعمال
بالغرامات ومصادره الممتلكات وازداد عدد
المباني السكنيه التي استولى عليها
المحتلون بعد ان هاجرها سكانها بشكل كبير
الروسيه فيما يتعلق بالوضع في سوريا »
نعم عبد القادر في البدايه ااا روسيا لم
تعلن رسميا على انها سيطرت على مدينه
سوليدار ولم يجري الحديث همم من اي طرف عن
هذا المعطى الجديد بل بالعكس شركه فاجنر
التي يراسها طبعا يفكيني بريكوجان كان قد
صرح بان المدينه ما زالت لم ااه تسيطر
عليها قواته هناك وهمم بل دعى حتى وسائل
الاعلام الروسيه الى همم الى تروي في نقل
المعلومات لتجنب تاثير تلك المعلومات على
السير المعارك لكن همم قوات همم لجانس
كالمواليه لروسيا اليوم قالت انها حصلت
اعلى معلومات استخباراتيه تفيد بتلقاه
الوحدات العسكريه الاوكرانيه داخل سوليدار
لاوامر عسكريه بالانسحاب من هذه المدينه
بعد تقدم قوات فاجنر منذ امس عندما سيطرت
على بل صغيره تقع الى جنوب من سوريا بلده
بخمسكوي والتوغل الى الاحياء الجنوبيه
والجنوبيه الغربيه من المدينه وماذا ذلك
نشرت قوه فاجنر صور لاحد توزهر احد
مقاتلها داخل مقلع او مصنع
لتدوير الملح باعتبار ان المدينه معروفه
بمقالي على الملح همم طبعا بعد ذلك ظهرت
ايضا صور اخرى لمعارك تدور داخل مباني
سكنيه في مدينه سوليدارو وبالتالي الروس
لم يتحدث قط عن انهم سيطروا بالكامل على
هذه المدينه بل اكدوا على انهم يحققون
تقدما بطيئا باتجاه الاحياء الوسطى من
المدينه في افق السيطره عليها كما يقولون
طبعا هذا التقدم همم
اذا سيطره القوات الروسيه على مدينه
سوليدار فذلك سيكون اول تقدم من نوعه منذ
ان كانت القوات الروسيه قد سيطرت على
مدينه سيفردانياس كواليتيتشانك الصيف
الماضي عبد القادر منذ ذلك الحين روسيا لم
تحقق اي تقدم عسكري كبير يضاهي سيطره على
مدينه من حجم همم سوليدار او حتى بخمونت
رغم ذلك ما زالت هناك معارك ايضا تدور في
محيط مدينه باخمت وحديث عن وصول مزيد من
الدعم العسكري والامدادات الى القوات
الروسيه التي تسعى الى قطر همم طرق
الامداد والمواصلات بين منطقه
في مدينه
السلطات المواليه لروسيا هناك اتهمت
القوات الاوكرانيه بانها لم تلتزم بيهدنه
وقف اطلاق النار التي اعلن عنها الرئيس
الروسي ودخلت حيزه تنفيذ متصف يوم امس
واتهمت بقذف طبعا بالقوات اوكرانيه لعدد
من الاحياء وهو ما اكدته بعد ذلك الوزاره
الدفاع الروسيه في بيانها اليوميه التي
قالت همم الجانب الروسي ملتزم بهذه الهدنه
حتى نهايتها منتصف الليله المقبله وانها
احبطت هجمات للقوات الاوكرانيه في محاور
عده من ابرزها طبعا كراسن لمان في مقاطعه
دونياسكو ومحور دونياسك وفي بعض المناطق
في زاباروجا وقالت بان همم طبعا قامت
بتدمير مواقع اطلاق النار الاخرانيه وقتلت
اكثر من 50 عسكريا همم اوكرانيا واتهمت
ايضا في المقابله الجيش الاوكراني بانه
وصل قصف المواقع الروسيه وايضا التجمعات
السكنيه فلنستمع الى ما قالته الوزاره في
هذا الشان
نلتقي اطلاق النار على طول يخطئ التماس في
اوكرانيا منذ منتصف السادس من يناير وصل
النظام كيف قصف التجمعات السكنيه ومواقع
جيشنا في محوري كريسنا والامان سن
الاوكرانيون 11 هجوما بالقضاء في عالم
مواقعنا وفي محاوله
ومارينكا استخدم العدو والمدفعيه ضد
وحدتنا احدى و50 مره كما اطلق الاوكرانيون
اكثر من 60 قذيفه على مناطق سكنيه في
مدينه دمياط والسادفت مدينه
نيران المدفعيه احدى 30 مره وفي خلص
10 مره قمنا بالردنا جميع اطلاق النار
الاخرانيه
شكرا لكم امين درغامي من موسكو وعمر الحاج
من دينيرو